[Music]
that's how about ghostbusters
I got to see it last night I really
enjoy such a great pass it's it's kind
of a dreamy cast it was so and with paul
feig directing and it just was what I'm
shocked is that Paul had enough footage
to kind of make a movie cuz with like
the four of us with Lesley Kate and
Kristen and I we've all been friends for
a long time so she Kristen I go back
like 16 years it was there's a lot of
chatter you know there's a lot of great
moments for you Kristen our Kristen Wiig
or just goofing around together and it
makes it anything starts like a weird
aunt like shoulder dance and Paul's like
okay let's we're still shooting and
we're like are you are yet like we just
can't I think it's like a whip and a
Taser together stew now there's
obviously when you signed up for this
movie you knew there's no way around
getting slimed that's just gonna be not
being in the film who do you think gets
it the worst for sure Kristen that's
what it looked like Kristen got it so
badly at one point Leslie grabbed her by
like the scruff of the neck and her
skirt like for the waistband and used
her as a human shield look for real it's
in the movie we're like that's where
Leslie's using Kristen as a human shield
but she just continuously got it like we
all got it a little bit but uh Kristen
kept getting it and it kept getting
funnier and funnier to me who every time
I was like oh no I'll stay with you
we're friends and all I did was it go
like as she's getting covered in candy
took a picture onset of fur coated
completely
[Laughter]
[Applause]
her eyes because she had so much in it
was like don't move and I think she
thought I was gonna be like I'll help
you I'm like I want to go get my camera
you're really good yeah but you got out
of it this is a sign you've made in this
business you got your own action figure
and that is a sign that you have finally
made it that's the law that's the
longest my torso has ever been right now
are your kids old enough to play with
and enjoy an action I brought them home
like four days ago I had brought all
four down and I was like what are they
gonna say and I was like we opened we
opened me up and then I heard them in
the other room really playing with them
like getro and they except they call it
they're like Kristen Leslie like they
don't know the character name biggest
movie and I went in and I was like I
wonder which one's me are they fighting
over me and this is I was like this on
the dining room table face down and they
had ruined the motorcycle and everybody
else like is anybody helping mom and
they're like
[Laughter]
you